hello and welcome to this mids suffer
Oban scrutiny and committee meeting I'm
James Casten um I'll be chairing this
meeting today uh may I first remind you
of the domestic Arrangements if you're
attending the meeting and speak and
persistently interrupt the meeting you
will be asked to leave please ensure
your mobile phones and laptops are on
silent additionally we will be using the
Evo in for this meeting on the modern.
goov app and the council members of the
public and the Press May record film
photograph or broadcast this meeting
when the public and press are not
lawfully excluded if you are intend to
do so please inform the committee clerk
if you hear the fire alarm please leave
the building immediately via the fire
exit and make your way to the assembly
point on epwi Town's football
ground follow the the signs directing
you to the fire exit at each end of the
floor do not enter the atrium if you are
in the atrium at the time of the alarm
follow the signs to the nearest fire
exit use the stairs not the lifts and do
not re-enter the building until you are
told it's safe to do
so so um we have um in attendance of
this meeting we have councelor Rachel
eurn the Cabinet member for finance and
resources and we have Melissa Evans
director for corporate resources and
section 15 one off officer and um we
also have Alysia Norman um as the lead
officer for over and scrutiny so um I'll
get to the agenda thank you very much um
apologies for absence and substitutions
please thank you chair we have apologies
from councelor Miles row but we do not
have have a substitute thank you okay
thank you um item two to receive
Declarations of Peary other registerable
or non-reg interest by
members I can't see any hands so um
there are none um item three to receive
notifications of petitions in accordance
with the council's petition scheme n
received CH questions by the public none
received questions by counselors un
received chair thank you thank you very
much so I'll move to the um main part of
this meeting which is item six MOS
2301 draft general fund assumptions for
2024 to
2025 um I'd like to invite councelor
eburn to introduce this report please
thank you very much chair and thank you
for inviting me to the committee today
um this this um paper that's before you
um is presented to the overview and
scrutiny committee to discuss and review
the assumptions currently being made in
preparation for the 2024 25 budget it
reflects changes expected in the cost of
services whether due to interest rates
inflation or other factors such as
housing growth and it also considers
potential changes in funding now there's
many factors um other factors being
considered not least the new ad
administration's priorities potential
changes to business rates such as those
influenced by Gateway 14
inide just um outside Stone Market and
also potential changes in investment
income these will all come forward in
the first dra of the budget um and the
committee will have full sight of them
at that at that time um it's worth
remembering also that while inflation is
now
4.6% um this time last year it's 11.1%
and no one forecast um that um just and
similarly um Bank base rate is now 5.25%
today um but the shortterm interest
rates are still high compared to where
they were last year so in the meantime
we'd really appreciate your comments um
on what we have today in the in the
paper today and um happy to take any
questions on that but for Technical and
very Financial ones I will um ask
Melissa to to take the answer to that
thank you thank you chair thank you very
much um Melissa would you are you
planning to say anything at this point
so we'll we'll go to questions from
counselors are there any questions
councelor scarf thanks chair I have a
number do you want me to deal with them
all in one go or just one by one um
however you choose to do it councelor
scaf well quite happy for you to then
the officers can get the answers to them
okay thank you thank you on the um
budget assumptions net cost of service
uh on the shared legal service I just
wanted to query on the bottom of page
six you've assumed 4% which is obviously
the same uh as the salary increase that
you've assumed in the payer board above
but you also say also say other costs
likely to increase so um A1 15,000
impact is barely 4% of the 41,000 budget
is is that enough in there because
you've got other costs we don't know
what those other costs are that's the
first
question yes if you're not y don't my
brain will hold on to more than one
question at time um so those are the
costs that have been put To Us by the
shared legal service so it's it's their
actual costs so there will be some
salaries element in there but there will
be some other costs as well so it's a
combination of both of those things but
that is the actual cost that they've
given us for next
year please um yeah just carry on asking
your
questions we take the answers the second
question is on the uh shared revenues
partnership and it says it's a 3%
increase the increase to the cost of
shared revenues partnership has
predominantly been on pay most other
costs have remain the same and vacancy
savings may have been delivered to help
mitigate this impact my my question
would be is the SRP able to deliver the
service that we expect of it by
mitigating these vacancy savings um I
can answer that chair if I may the um I
think with the SRP whenever there's um
any sort of changes to policy or changes
to work being done they tend to kind of
review um the Staffing and other
resources that they need to do that and
so they're almost constantly reviewing
so what they find is actually um they
are able to kind of streamline some of
their practices um and and change some
of the Staffing Arrangements accordingly
and and final question uh chair uh page
eight refers to the suffer business
rates pool um and we're assuming there's
no top slicing of growth uh for the
forthcoming year obviously that's
different to what we've had in the past
where we have top sliced uh with the
suff authorities joining together in
order to deliver that um impact uh on
the right hand side of the page
is it something that we make as a
unilateral decision not to do or is it
something that you've got an indication
from the other business author the other
authorities that they are going to do
the
same chair if I if I may answer that um
I understand that the the decision will
be made by all the authorities within
the public sector leaders group but that
um more than one has made a request that
those that top slicing doesn't happen so
it is likely that the probability of
that decision being going through is is
pretty high I'd say does that answer
your
question just to clarify then so if if
more than one Authority do not take part
in the top slicing does that mean that
that top sliting only occurs in those
authorities that select to take part or
does it mean that the whole scheme fails
across supper um through you chair it
has to happen across the board so if if
one said we wanted to
top slicing to keep continuing and the
others said no then it would it would go
ahead it's got to be um All or Nothing
as it
were thank you very much um I'll just
ask a question and here with for casting
a reduction of income from um
development management um it says um
uncertainty in the housing market could
we just um could you just talk a little
bit about what the con how you came to
the conclusion and the basis of that
decision please um thank you chair I can
start on this one I think with the um
you know we've seen significant housing
growth in mids suffk and therefore the
um planning fees that go along with that
and I think the there's now been more of
a Slowdown in that and therefore the
expectation is that level of of um sort
of major developments isn't going to
continue um and that is one of the
reasons
why that's been forecast I understand
that the planning um Department as it
were are looking at the planning service
are looking at ways of improving that
position and they're doing a lot more
work on it so we're hopeful that that
might not be the case but also that
ultimately it'll be kind of backed up by
some good rationale for
that thank you um any oh councilor
Carter
please yes I've received a a question
from from um councilor R Who
unfortunately could be here uh regarding
supplies and services in the um
assumptions um they ask if there is a
way to provide a range for gas or
electric uh for it if it is in a a high
use year EG hot summer and cold winter a
mid use and a low use um EG and
unfortunately would be when I there we
go uh low use mild or year given the
potential effect effect of a climate
crisis on energy
usage thank you um I'm not quite sure
how the modeling has been done I assume
it's probably been based on the previous
year's run rate if you like so we can
certainly have a look at some different
scenarios to see whether you know if it
was particularly hot summer what it
might look like for a lower usage so we
can certainly have a look at that but I
assume I think it's probably based on
kind of the last 12 months kind of run
rate so yeah we can have a look at
that thank you may ask we have yes
please yes we have a
question well range kind of FS into US
is regarding Gateway 14 whereas we have
got I believe we have an income coming
in and we have some figures of what
money we should be receiving but it's
not Incorporated in this is there reason
why it can't be incorporated or is there
likely to be incorporated later for next
year
yeah thank you um yes at the moment
we're just working with Gateway 14
limited to see what kind of the size of
the dividend might be coming back to the
council and you know the timing of that
and how much that's likely to be so we
are having a look at the dividend policy
with the company so at the moment we
haven't bottomed out those numbers but
if there is a benefit for next year as
we get closer to budget setting we
certainly will build that in but it's
just too early at this stage to build
that
in can I
um and just to add to that I'd hope that
we're in a position um uh when you see
the full draft budget in January I hope
that that would be all included um so
that there' be you know be complete
picture at that
point thank you very much any other
questions um councelor
maton yes um thank you um yeah I was
wondering looking at the gas and
electricity and the fuel costs um
whether there's any
um investment um planned which would
reduce our usage on either of those two
headings um and if we know yet what
proportion of them is is um fossil fuel
or or not fossil
[Music]
fuel I think that's probably one I'll
have to take away and come back if
that's okay because I don't have that
have that detail thank
you thank you very much um councelor
Whitehead thank you chair um the
equivalent equivalent report brought to
on last year was headed up um um general
fund and housing revenue account budget
assumptions so I was just wondering why
there were no HRA budget assumptions
being to overview and scrutiny because I
think last year with the renting Council
house rent increases that was probably
more controversial than the general
fund yeah so um we're currently doing
the work on the HRA 30e business plan so
I think until we've done more work on
that we can't accurately say what some
of those assumptions might be
particularly around the rent increases
until we know what the costs are of that
service because we don't want to assume
a rent increase if if we don't need to
equally as costs are going up we we
potentially would need to build
something in so we are working on that
at the moment but we haven't finalized
that so those numbers will be coming
back to January overviewing scrutiny so
you will be seeing something before it
goes to
C thank you very much um councelor Whit
had another just a couple more um with
business rates um I think it's already
been mentioned about Gateway 14 it says
it could be a sign well it will be a
significant positive impact when the
large range
comes online which I think well I think
several of us are going to the unve
quite a lot of people are going to the
unveiling tomorrow and it says the
timing of this is very much dependent on
the valuation office rating the sites as
they are occupied so I'm just
questioning in terms of how that how
that works because people if you move
into a domestic dwelling you're very
much paying from the day you move in so
um the uh how does it actually work with
the evaluation office with these big um
warehouses
um so once the range has been fully
fitted out the valuation office will be
instructed to to go out and value the
site but what will happen is they'll
backdate it to the time when it was
occupied so even though it might not be
you know they don't issue the bill
straightway it will be backdated to the
to the right date so they won't get any
free free period if you
like and I think if I can just add to
you chair that the until we know that
you know because it's dependent on
valuation office we can't kind of you
know we can make a few assumptions but
we need to know
it yeah please carry on I was going to
say the point being that it is a big
number and to look at the big picture
you need the big numbers the other
question in terms of business rates and
the zero increased consumption is I mean
I think quite a few things like for
example Port one at Great blenham built
during this year so there must be an
annualized effect of say half a year
this year and a full year next year I
just wonder how that could be built into
the model
yeah I think once we know the figures
then obviously the equivalent report
this time next year will be be different
because we'll have more certainty of
those um you know I don't think until
we've got any certainty we should be
putting forward um figures and
assumptions now on
that so and just one final question the
SRP shows 3% assumption but it's going
up 241,000 or 22% so um given that yes
generally brings its some figures in
within budget I'm rather surprised at
that increase what's the
explanation most most of the increase is
Staffing so it's 3% on the payward that
they're assuming for next year but a lot
of the other costs they've absorbed
within the running cost so it has
brought it down less than what it would
normally be so they have absorbed some
of those those costs by making savings
elsewhere um in some of their contracts
for things like printing um are is like
that so the 3% is on the salaries but
then there's other things that that's
covering that as
well thank you very much um in regards
to the new homes bonus um I've done
quite a few of these um meetings now and
I've heard this ever such a lot that we
we don't know we have to assume that we
won't have a no no new homes bonus um
the year after next
um how can you just explain what what's
happening with that and um why we have
that
uncertainty
please I think for the chair if I may
the last couple of years the when when
news homes bonus was first
um agreed as it were as a funding stream
in 2011 it was done on a kind of
six-year basis then that moved to
four-year basis but the last couple of
years it's been on a onee only so the
funding kind of arrangement that was
agreed last year on about the 20th of
December it normally is um was that it
would be for one year so we will now
wait until um I think it's we're
expected to hear on the 22nd of December
so that whether that new homes bonus
will be for another one year but this
time last year they
said government said it is one year only
um the hope would be that they would
then say yes you've got another one year
of new homes bonus or there's something
new coming in its place um
but nobody knows at the
moment I won't I won't debate but it
seems like it's such an important part
of these figures and it's very difficult
to um go not not know whether we're
getting it or not um but yeah it like I
say it's seems to have been like that
for quite a while um do I have any
further questions on this
no so um we'll go into um debate would
anyone like to um talk on
this I am for me it's good to see this
nice and early um to be prepared for it
it's um we we're still waiting for quite
a bit of detail but I think it's I think
it's really important to get to it early
so we can sort of follow it through this
will be the first of a few
a couple of meet or three meetings maybe
yeah on this so um it's good to to get
this early look at it it does seem to me
like things are fairly healthy it is a a
bit of a worry going forward um and a
lot of that does depend on the new homes
bonus which we've just discussed um so
um yeah for me yeah thank you very much
for this it's um it's good to see does
anyone else want to um C councelor scarf
yes thank you chair yeah I mean at at
this stage I think the assumptions um
that you've presented to um the
overviewing scrutiny committee are fair
assumptions and obviously as the chair
has just said there'll be a lot more
information coming out and hopefully by
the time we get to our January meeting
we'll be in a much better position to
know exactly what is going on and let us
hope that there is no nasty surprises uh
in terms of um our contribution from
from from government but I think it's a
fair assumption at the moment chair as
you've just
outlined thank you very much um would
anybody it's it's quite a difficult one
to make recommendations on I think a
recommendation would be how we can make
the information more accessible for the
next meeting I think we've we've done
this several times and we've we've got a
very good sort of format for that
information but um if um yeah if um if
there's no recommendations on this I'm
quite happy to um take this to you um
could I have a
proposer to for this thank you councilor
scarf could I have a seconder thank you
very much and we we'll take this for the
recommendation to the vote um please
make that vote now thank you thank you
chair so members we're voting on the
recommendation that's listed in report
and this would just be 2.1 that the
draft budget assumptions are set out in
the report for for the 20242 general
fund budget be
noted and if you give me a moment I will
just start that on
modg thank you members that is now in
progress you to
vote
thank you chair that is five votes for
stat unim
yes thank you very much um thank you to
the um the portfolio holder and the um
officer for attending the meeting um
I'll now move on to the next item on the
um agenda which is the um
m2302 forcoming decision list um does
anybody want to comment on that
forthcoming decision
list
no okay that's for that's for noting so
we'll move on to item 8 MOS
2303 mids overview and scrutiny work
plan um I'll pass you over to Alysia
who's got an update on
it thank you chair so this morning we
had the Baba only overview and scrutiny
committee and when discussing the work
plan item it was agreed by uh the
members of the bab committee that we
would do an item in January or February
time on a review on the number of
officers working from home and
productivity levels uh I wanted to
assess whether mid suffk would be keen
on making that a joint item and putting
on their work plan as well or otherwise
it would remain a babon item but I just
wanted to put that to the committee for
consideration thank you chair right I'm
happy for anyone to comment on that or
um if any anybody's got a problem with
us doing that as a joint committee they
could they could say
now um councelor Matson I'm afraid
you're not a member of the committee is
it is it something that's very important
for this
item I just wanted to say I've actually
got a question that I asked um ahead of
our last um group meeting um o of the
officers um to get the stati itics out
on that and I haven't seen the answer
yet so um I I'll um see if I can get
that answer to you um if you're going to
discuss it in January yeah thank you
very much that would be very useful and
we will um we will do that as a joint
meeting because um it seems like the
Committees um wants to do that so um
yeah if we could um if we could include
that in the um work the The Joint
scrutiny work plan um that is for noting
so um thank you all um I think I'm
concluding the meeting in record time so
um um thank you very much and um you'll
all um have a bit more time before full
council at half five so um yeah thank
you for
attending